what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and the mcu is getting a
lot bigger and we got some really really
exciting news today concerning deadpool
3 which of course is now going to take
place inside of the marvel cinematic
universe moon knight season 2 that's
right moon knight season 2 which has
been directly teased by oscar isaac and
of course mutants now of course mutants
are what everybody is waiting for right
now we already have kamala khan as the
first mutant in the mcu but now fans are
wondering who else they're going to
introduce who is going to be the first
comic mutant in the mcu because of
course no offense to kamala khan but in
the comics she's an inhuman not a mutant
will marvel studios give us wolverine
soon could storm appear in black panther
2 and is deadpool going to be a part of
the actual x-men team these are all
things we want to know and luckily for
us we are getting closer and closer each
day starting with some awesome deadpool
3 news today and hey if you love marvel
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos so
deadpool 3 is one of the most
anticipated projects coming up
presumably in phase six now i've already
done a couple of videos on what i expect
from phase six and yes i do believe that
deadpool is going to be one of these
slots in phase six that marvel hasn't
revealed yet and now based off of the
news that we have today that's pretty
much all but confirmed as deadpool 3 has
begun ryan reynolds is now working on
getting back in deadpool shape not that
he's really out of shape right now he
just wants to get in better shape and of
course you have to be in really good
condition to be able to do some of the
stunts that he's going to do himself but
his personal trainer took to instagram
to announce that him and ryan reynolds
are now preparing for deadpool 3. his
fitness trainer is don saladino and he
shared two pictures of him with ryan
reynolds and just to confirm that this
is indeed for deadpool 3 the caption for
the instagram post was a red circle with
two swords and it says and so it begins
confirming that this is training for
deadpool 3. now deadpool 3 is actually
really underway already ryan reynolds
has been working on the script for years
and he originally had help from the mala
no sisters writing the script then they
got the writers rhett reese and paul
wernick who wrote the first two deadpool
movies who are now writing for deadpool
3 as well with ryan reynolds and they've
also been working on this script for a
while and ryan reynolds shared a picture
with him at marvel studios a long time
ago over a couple of years ago he
actually posted the picture of him at
marvel studios on his instagram on
october 14th of 2019 and of course we
have director sean levy who directed the
movie free guy also starring ryan
reynolds of course he will be directing
deadpool 3. so a lot is underway and
it's really exciting because deadpool
creator rob lightfield has actually
teased cameos for deadpool 3. at this
year's san diego comic-con rob lyfield
was asked about how excited he was to
see deadpool team up with other mcu
characters and this is what he said i
will have my picket line i will have my
single picket line of one okay don't
tease me with number two don't take me
to valhalla and then drop me off okay
look we both know deadpool 3 he's going
to interact with uh the crew you know i
mean i get excited at the prospect of
him hanging out with hemsworth and or uh
you know ant-man mr paul rudd i mean
those are great matchups so right here
rob liefeld has already teased cameos in
deadpool 3 when he says we both know
deadpool 3 he's going to interact with
uh the crew you know so right here he's
basically saying look we know cameos are
coming in deadpool 3 and the way he says
the crew you know makes it seem like
he's actually going to be interacting
with some avengers which of course would
make sense and is what everybody really
wants the only question is who exactly
will he be interacting with and because
of this question i actually kind of hope
deadpool 3 comes after they introduce
the mutants into the mcu or the official
x-men team so deadpool can interact with
the mutants we only kind of had him
interacting with mutants and deadpool
and deadpool 2. we did have a really
funny cameo of the x-men team from the
fox universe and deadpool 2. but i would
really love some full-on interactions
with deadpool and characters like
professor xavier storm and i actually do
think him and ant-man would have some
pretty funny banter and rob liefeld
actually says that he would love to see
him with the hulk because he would love
to see the hulk smash him kind of like
he did loki which i think would be
pretty funny as well there are a ton of
possibilities for deadpool 3 and the
mutants in the mcu which we'll talk
about in just a bit but first let's talk
about this moon knight season 2 teaser
that we got from oscar isaac himself
moon knight was very successful across
most of the entire marvel fandom it's
become a lot of people's favorite disney
plush show from marvel it's also in the
top three for a lot of people i've heard
and i also personally think that it's
one of the best shows as well and before
season one came out and during and after
season one came out there was a lot of
confusion about if there was going to be
a season two because a lot of the people
from marvel studios said that it was
supposed to be kind of a one-off show
just a one-time thing but check out what
oscar isaac says in this tick tock from
user haya tia which i probably didn't
say that right my apologies but let's
check it out here the question on
everyone's mind is there season two
why else will we be in cairo
so in this tick tock we can actually see
moon knight director muhammad dayab and
of course oscar isaac and apparently
based off of what oscar isaac says they
are in cairo the capital of egypt the
question is are we going to be getting a
season two the director plays coy and
asks if they're talking about moon
knight in which oscar azdek replies why
else would we be in cairo now i would be
shocked if they didn't do a second
season not only did moon knight have
massive success but also oscar isaac is
really tight with disney remember he was
in star wars and i doubt they would
introduce moon knight for just one
season have him be this one-off thing in
the mcu and then never see him again i
really really doubt marvel studios would
do that and of course everybody is
hoping that moon knight is going to be
an avenger and they did tease us with
jake lockley at the very end of moon
night season one and clearly konchu lied
and has not really left the body of mark
stephen jake of course jake is aware of
this but mark and steven aren't aware of
jake so there is a lot of story left to
tell here and it really does seem like
they are going to give us a season 2 but
now the question is based off of what
oscar isaac just said and based off of
the fact that they're in cairo are they
actually filming season 2 right now
could moon knight season 2 be one of the
projects that have not been announced
for phase six i would not be surprised
at all if it's one of those slots now
this could be just the two of them in
cairo having a good time but they do
kind of hint that that is why they're in
cairo and it would kind of be a mean
prank if they were teasing us about a
season two if it's not really going to
happen so fingers crossed for a moon
night season 2 and d23 is right around
the corner about a month away so if it
is coming in season six we'll find out
very soon i'm hoping at d23 they will
announce deadpool 3 and give us an
official release date and then of course
talk about the mutants kevin feige has
been teasing the future and miss marvel
set up kamala khan as the first mutant
in the mcu so the mutants are already
here at this point in time we're just
waiting for an official project solely
dedicated to either one mutant or the
mutant team the x-men of course because
this is all going to tie together for
secret wars hopefully hopefully moon
knight is there hopefully deadpool is
there and we know he's going to be there
because he's going to enter the mcu
before then but hopefully they introduce
the mutants so some mutant characters
can be a part of secret wars as well
with all of their variants but i want to
know what mutants you would like to see
in the mcu who is your favorite who
would you like to see and who would you
like to see them with let me know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below please don't forget to like the
video and subscribe if you love marvel
you can always follow me on twitter for
live updates and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof
you